[Musique]
quelqu'un à qui parler film écrit et
réalisé par Anne-Sophie Reinhardt
angoisse isolement des tresses sociales
et psychologiques voilà ce cantonent les
bénévoles et professionnels de santé
mentale qu'est-ce que cela dit de notre
société doit-on en tirer des
enseignements plus généraux sur la façon
dont nous fonctionnons dont nous vivons
dont nous communiquons parlons-en avec
nos invités alain Milon bienvenue vous
êtes sénateur LR de Vaucluse
vice-président de la commission des
affaires sociales vous avez notamment
présidé la mission d'information sur la
situation de la psychiatrie des mineurs
en France et je précise parce que c'est
important que vous êtes aussi médecin
Ghislaine de saigne bienvenue à vous
également vous êtes présidente fédérale
de SOS Amitié c'est une association qui
existe depuis plus de 60 ans qui
regroupe environ 1800 bénévoles vous
avez été vous-même écoutante ce qu'on
appelle écoutante pendant plusieurs
années donc vous connaissez parfaitement
le sujet Caroline Dublanche bienvenue à
vous également vous êtes psychologue
vous êtes aussi à votre manière une
écoute puisque vous animez une émission
d'écoute sur RTL parlons-nous il y a du
lundi au jeudi de 22h à minuit et demi
et pendant près de 20 ans vous avez
animé libre antenne sur Europe 1
professeur Antoine pélissolo bienvenue à
vous également vous êtes psychiatre chef
de service dans le pôle de psychiatrie
du CHU Henri mondorc à Créteil
spécialiste des troubles anxieux et de
la dépression et vous venez de publier
avec Christophe André et Patrick Légeron
la nouvelle peur des autres chez Odile
Jacob merci beaucoup à tous les quatre
d'être ici ce film est touchant je l'ai
dit il dit beaucoup sur la détresse des
gens mais ce qu'on a envie de savoir
c'est si il y a un effet de loop ou si
il y a on peut considérer qu'il y a un
vrai problème de mal-être social
généralisable qu'en pensez-vous
professeur poly solo alors c'est
évidemment une fenêtre très intéressante
on peut dire il y a les fait loupe
peut-être mais en tout cas la fenêtre
c'est un peu comme dans nos cabinets
parce que moi j'ai vu beaucoup de choses
évidemment voisines de du mal-être en
effet du sentiment de d'isolement
et du besoin de parler quoi tout
simplement le besoin de s'exprimer et je
pense que ce qui peut être tendance de
la société c'est le décalage entre le
côté un peu factice des échanges qu'on
peut avoir de plus en plus parce qu'on
est censé avoir de plus en plus d'outils
de communication et la réalité de
certaines personnes alors pourquoi
probablement pas de la totalité des
personnes mais quand même une bonne
partie de celle qui finalement se
retrouve quand même seul sans pouvoir
échanger et je sais que la solitude est
un facteur de souffrance très important
Caroline Dublanche vous observez
même
film vous a paru
être un zoom et du coup donner
l'impression que que cette société va
mal ou vous aussi en tant qu'écoutante
dans vos émissions de radio vous le
ressentez oui c'est toujours difficile
de généraliser de dire que la société va
mal mais il y a beaucoup de gens qui
vont mal et moi ce que j'ai retrouvé une
atmosphère quelque chose de très
familier dans dans ce documentaire dans
ces personnes qui appellent les
écoutants aussi j'ai été frappé enfin
admirative de la qualité d'écoute et la
qualité de leur présence
vraiment c'est ce qui c'est ce qui m'a
touché on les sent pleinement investi
impliqués on y reviendra certainement
sur les difficultés de ce rôle
d'écoutant je la solitude en fait on
pourrait croire que c'est quelque chose
on le confond avec l'isolement souvent
et quand j'ai démarré l'émission la
solitude c'était surtout des personnes
âgées qui m'ont parlé
et au fil du temps j'ai vu évoluer et en
fait c'est c'est tout le monde quel que
soit l'âge mais de fait et ça on le sait
en tant que psy en tant qu'écoutante en
tant que médecin quand on souffre quand
on est confronté à un problème quand on
nous apprend qu'on a atteint d'une
maladie ou donc on vient de perdre un
proche de fait même si on est entouré on
est seul face à cette souffrance
vous avez été touché par ce documentaire
il dit quelque chose pour vous de la
société dans laquelle nous vivons
aujourd'hui il dit un mal-être un
malaise sociétal social
je vais pas revenir à ce qu'on dit les
spécialistes le psychiatres et le
psychologue pour moi l'effet de loupe il
existe mais il existe dans le sens où il
permet aux autres de prendre conscience
qui a un problème majeur qui est celui
de l'isolement et de la solitude celui
des gens qui de nos concitoyens qui sont
désespérés par les situations qu'ils
peuvent vivre à titre personnel ou par
les situations que l'on peut vivre
lorsque l'information vous parvient je
crois que le vrai problème l'un des
vrais problèmes pardon c'est c'est la
masse considérable d'informations
négatives que reçoivent en permanence
tous les jours nos concitoyens que ce
soit la situation de la France que soit
une situation économique que soit la
situation guerrière en Europe de l'Est
écologique de soi la situation guérir en
Afrique que soit les accidents de
voiture des tas de choses qui peuvent à
un moment ou un autre perturbé
profondément le mental le moral de nos
concitoyens que soient la crise
sanitaire on va certainement en parler
mais le confinement a joué un rôle
considérable dans la façon dont nous
citoyens en particulier les jeunes ont
ressenti ce confinement et la solitude
on parlera des jeunes tout à l'heure
effectivement parce que c'est un vrai
sujet Ghislaine de saigne vous
connaissez par cœur ce sujet dans le
film la réalisatrice nous dit que ces
plateformes d'écoute c'est plus de 3
millions d'appels chaque année est-ce
que c'est un chiffre en augmentation
est-ce qu'on a une société qui va de
plus en plus mal et des gens qui ont de
plus en plus besoin de parler
le plus en plus besoin de parler c'est
évident comme le disait le professeur en
début d'émission besoin de parler c'est
une évidence l'être humain ne se réalise
que par rapport au contact qui peut
avoir avec d'autres donc plus qu'avant
ou pas alors plus qu'avant plus qu'avant
le covid peut-être oui en tout cas nous
un SOS Amitié nous le ressentons un peu
plus pourquoi
parce qu'effectivement nous recevons sur
la plateforme nationale 3300
000 appels pour 2022 et nous en
décrochons à peu près un peu plus de 600
000 donc c'est un rapport de 1/5 vous
manquez de bénévoles vous mangez bien
sûr même si nous avons 1800 bénévoles
nous manquons de bénévoles je vais
donner un chiffre qui va parler je pense
à tout le monde par rapport au nombre
d'heures d'écoute je prends que le
chiffre 2022 par rapport au nombre
d'heures d'écoute que le 1800 bénévoles
ont fait ça représente plus de 120 ETTP
équivalent en plein d'accord donc voilà
ça pose quand même un petit peu parce
que vous êtes très sélectif sur les
profils parce qu'il faut une formation
ou parce qu'il y a peu de volontaires
alors un peu des deux
sélectif bien évidemment parce que la
première responsabilité qu'on peut avoir
en tant que responsable de d'une telle
d'un tel service d'écoute c'est de
protéger les écoutants par rapport à ce
qu'ils entendent
vous le disiez très justement je veux
dire les gens sont vraiment une charge
importante d'une multitude de
problématiques qu'on a qu'on est amené à
entendre donc bien évidemment nous avons
une formation très solide sur le sujet
et un suivi psychologique et un suivi
psychologique bien évidemment régulier
toutes les trois semaines ça c'est
indispensable Caroline Dublanche vous
parliez de ses écoutantes tout à l'heure
qui était remarquable effectivement dans
ce film est-ce que vous vous protégez
est-ce que vous vous êtes parfois aussi
abîmé parce que vous entendez cette
détresse à laquelle vous répondez tous
les soirs on ne sort pas toujours indem
c'est c'est compliqué d'être
parfois on le dit dans le documentaire
il y en écoutant qui dit
on se sent impuissant enfin il y a des
moments on est face à nos limites mais
bon notre formation
nous apprend à reconnaître déjà nos
limites à faire avec il faut pas être
celui qui trouve qui cherche des
solutions absolument et il faut pas
créer vachement non plus non alors c'est
intéressant cette notion d'attachement
parce que parce que je crois que un
moment il est aussi un peu inévitable
mais je comprends ce que vous voulez
dire c'est à dire que moi je précise
bien qu'à la radio ça ne peut pas
s'apparenter à une consultation avec un
psychiatre avec un psychologue enfin
c'est une émission de radio on peut
s'exprimer et donc il faut pas créer que
la personne nous prenne pour son psy
mais ce qui est intéressant c'est qu'il
y a tous ceux qui écoutent contrairement
effectivement
SOS Amitié il y a l'écoutant et la
personne qui appelle qui est en détresse
là il y a tous les auditeurs et il y a
ce lien qui se crée il y a cette
intimité qu'il y a une solidarité qui se
met en place qui est invisible mais qui
est là elle est pas invisible parce que
à travers les messages les commentaires
et je trouve que c'est très réconfortant
parce qu'à l'heure des réseaux sociaux
qui véhiculent quand même beaucoup de
choses négatives parfois de la violence
de la haine il y a une dimension
vraiment affective un désir d'aider des
gens qui se retrouvent dans une histoire
à tel point que des personnes maintenant
me disent j'espère qu'il y a des
personnes qui vont réagir à mon nez à
mon témoignage c'est pas neutre de
parler publiquement de pouvoir dire
cette souffrance et en fait qu'elle soit
partagée et qu'elle puisse être comprise
ça fait presque partie de la thérapie
quoi professeur alors en tout cas la
radio alors moi j'ai toujours été fan de
notamment de ses horaires des coudes
parce que en effet un climat mais en
tout cas pour les personnes que l'on
rencontre qui sont souffrances souvent
la radio c'est le compagnon le seul
compagnon c'est vraiment
essentiels à évaluer leur efficacité
pardon pour le terme parce qu'il est un
peu dur mais c'est vraiment très
différent déjà entre la radio et la
plateforme c'est encore différent
puisque effectivement le les écoutant
qui sont pas les mêmes mais le fait de
pouvoir avoir des interlocuteurs pour
des personnes qui sont pas forcément
malades puisque vraiment il y a il y a
bon
personnes qui ont des troubles mentaux
donc normalement suivis pris en charge
et puis des personnes qui ont besoin de
parler qui ont besoin d'avoir quelqu'un
à qui parler de tout parce que quand on
a des bons des événements difficiles
quand on ne peut pas le se confier c'est
très douloureux mais même quand on a des
événements positifs quand on fait un
truc sympa on a toujours envie de se
dire mais je vais raconter à quelqu'un
quand on a personne en fait parce que
personne n'est là soit présent soit à
distance c'est là qu'il y a une
disponible tout simplement disponible
exister pour quelqu'un vraiment
l'origine de la souffrance maximale
c'est ça je n'existe pour personne et là
il y a quelqu'un qui est là et pour
terminer sur votre question on ne sait
pas évaluer effectivement quel est le
bénéfice en tout cas on a passé ces
outils là global globalement mais par
contre on sait que pouvoir orienter
quand c'est nécessaire et je crois que
c'est ce que font la plupart vers des
soins parce que clairement il y a des
gens qui ont besoin d'une thérapie c'est
quand même une étape essentielle je
voudrais rebondir sur ce que vous avez
dit pour pour dire que finalement dans
cette société et c'est un petit peu l'un
des randomages il y a de moins en moins
de contacts personnalisés de contacts
individuels on est de plus en plus dans
des réseaux des réseaux sociaux qui
empêchent la parole qui empêche le
contact qui empêche la prise de
conscience que l'autre peut nous
entendre et peut nous soutenir et ça
c'est important et vous faites le lien
avec l'extrait que je voudrais vous
montrer à présent ce qui peut y avoir
beaucoup d'explications à cette détresse
on l'a dit un chômage isolement problème
d'argent addiction on va peut-être y
revenir d'ailleurs mais il y en a une
principale c'est qu'effectivement nous
ne communiquons plus beaucoup entre nous
le lien social c'est distendu notamment
avec l'arrivée des outils technologiques
et c'est ce que dit l'une des bénévoles
dans le film écouter
une voie humaine ben ça devient rare tu
appelles ton serveur parce que ta télé
en panne ta boîte est en panne et ben
c'est tapé un tapé 2 on vous envoie un
SMS et sur le SMS est écrit coucou vous
pouvez vous dépanner tout seul allez sur
le site machin et jamais de voix humaine
c'est effrayant
de sanielle a raison est-ce qu'on vit
dans des sociétés un peu déshumanisées
oui complètement alors que les personnes
habitent en milieu urbain ou en milieu
rural en fait le phénomène est
voilà il se diffuse complètement alors
c'est comparable on se sent pas plus
isolés à la campagne qu'en ville
peut-être même l'inverse non pas
forcément et l'arrivée de ces répondeurs
c'est réponses par SMS ces choses une
souffrance en général pour ces personnes
là en tout cas pour les personnes qui
nous appellent pourquoi parce que déjà
quand quelqu'un est il y a beaucoup de
difficultés que ce soit au niveau de la
précarité et au niveau de de sa vie tout
court il est déjà moins enclin à aller
sur les réseaux sociaux aller sur des
mécanismes numériques on va vous dire
on est voilà ils ont besoin d'un appui
et d'une aide effectivement la voix
humaine tout simplement avec ce qu'elle
véhicule de d'émotion de je vous reçois
je qui nous donne et bien tout ça
n'existe pas avec le côté numérique donc
ça pose problème et ces personnes là on
souffre ça rajoute une couche en fait et
c'est un immense paradoxe Caroline
Dublanche on n'a jamais eu autant
d'outils de communication pour
communiquer entre nous pour soi-disant
faire société et en fait on est de plus
en plus isolé donc mais communiquer
n'est pas parlé il n'y a qu'un
interroger les communicants enfin bon il
communique oui mais parler
c'est tout autre chose et vous avez
raison de dire la voix rien ne pourra
remplacer la voix humaine la voix moi je
le sais particulièrement à ces heures là
de la nuit la voix ça apaise pour avoir
travaillé aussi au sein de l'hôpitaux
toutes les équipes soignantes savent à
quel point la nuit tout prend des
proportions surdimensionnées et qui est
de l'angoisse qui surgit et le fait
d'avoir une présence alors c'est le
contact aussi le toucher mais une voix
elle dégage ce que vous dites cette
émotion cette proximité
la présence qui rassure est-ce qu'on
pourrait faire machine arrière est-ce
qu'on pourrait les retirer c'est
répondeurs est-ce qu'on pourrait mettre
remettre on devrait personnellement
c'est un cri du coeur mais ça vous
semble impossible c'est c'est un
paquebot à faire reculer c'est tout est
très déshumanisé son compter tous ces
gens qui n'ont pas accès ou numérique
parce que c'est une véritable exclusion
ça aussi dans le film il y a une femme
qui confie qu'elle n'a pas entendu
prononcer son prénom depuis plus de 3
ans c'est complètement bouleversant on
vit dans des sociétés d'anonymes oui
alors je crois que les automatisation
c'est le pire c'est vraiment dans la vie
courante les commerçants par exemple
tout bêtement parce que citer les
livrets les livreurs mais maintenant il
y a des magasins où tout se fait
automatiquement avec des caisses
automatiques et donc certains magasins
ont dû rajouter moi j'ai vu je sais plus
dans quelle chaîne ils ont créé des
blablacaisse où on peut parler avec la
caissière c'est-à-dire que là on peut
prendre un petit peu le temps et pour
échangé parce qu'il y a des gens qui qui
rencontrent les seules personnes dans
leur journée c'est le boulanger
le marchand à côté donc c'est vraiment
vital cet échange là qui est souvent de
la petite conversation comme on dit des
échanges effectivement c'est pas de la
grande communication mais c'est ça la
nourriture affective c'est vraiment la
conversation c'est-à-dire parler de tout
et de rien mais dans lequel on va petit
à petit faire un lien et se connaître
enfin c'est vraiment essentiel et et
autour de cette absence de communication
je pense que chez les jeunes qui eux ont
les outils les réseaux enfin les
échanges ils communiquent énormément
parce que si on comptait le nombre de
d'interactions ils en ont énormément
mais souvent il y a c'est une
confrontation c'est il faut que je me
montre il y a une performance et on
n'est pas dans dans l'échange
complètement spontané qui crée ce
sentiment d'appartenance de du
diapositif
et c'est souvent voilà et c'est souvent
méchant vous faites bien de parler des
jeunes on va s'arrêter effectivement sur
le profil de ceux qui appellent ces
plateformes alors dans le film on
comprend que ce sont toutes les
catégories sociales en revanche il y a
effectivement un profil nouvelle
représenté d'après en tout cas les
bénévoles qui se confient dans ce film
écoutez
avant on en avait quasiment jamais
depuis le confinement on a quand même
des jeunes qui appellent tu vois là il y
a eu 24 ans 17 ans rien que ce soit tu
vois avant c'était très très rare
[Musique]
une fois il y en a un qui est qui
appelle
et qui dit
ma fenêtre est ouverte dites moi ce
qu'il faut faire parce que j'ai une
envie irrésistible de sauter par la
fenêtre
un jeune étudiant
elle a mis non c'est nouveau ça jeunesse
qui semble montrer beaucoup de détresse
vous avez vous travaillez à la figure
sur la psychiatrie pour les jeunes mais
on est face à un réel problème
oui on est face réel problème je ne
pense pas que ce soit ouvertement
tellement nouveau en ce que ça a été
provoqué par la crise covid je pense que
c'est provoqué comme disait le
professeur par les réseaux je pense que
c'est provoqué par l'absence de contact
direct et
est-ce qu'on peut revenir en arrière
j'en sais rien je pense non
malheureusement parce qu'il faudrait
peut-être c'est essayer de d'écouter un
peu plus les psychologues et les
psychiatres et faire en sorte que on
donne la possibilité à chacun nos
concitoyens en particulier aux jeunes et
au très jeune
la possibilité de faire du sport la
possibilité
de discuter avec leur enseignant la
possibilité de parler enfin avec leurs
parents à table en particulier parce que
la plupart du temps maintenant qu'on
voyait des des familles au restaurant
ailleurs chacun est en effet autour de
la table mais chacun est avec son
portable en train de de communiquer par
le téléphone
rééducation des parents ça passe vous en
tant que sénateur quand vous voyez ce
type de problème vous dites que vous
commencez par quoi ça passe par une
rééducation peut-être des politiques
d'avoir plus que des parents parce que
nous aussi
en matière de politique on se laisse un
qui peut envahir par par ce qu'on
appelle la modernité et parce qu'on
appelle l'intelligence artificielle mais
je ne suis pas sûr que
la solution soit là les seuls qui
réillent réellement entre en contact
actuellement ce sont les psychiatres
parce que c'est leur métier parce qu'il
refuse de faire autrement ils reçoivent
leur passion les psychiatres reçoivent
des patients qui ont véritablement des
pathologies médicales importantes mais
les psychologues qui reçoivent quand
même en dehors de la radio les
psychologues reçoivent les patients ils
les écoutent et le contact l'écoute et
la conversation et puis peut-être aussi
dire ben non
dire le contraire ou essayer d'amener la
personne vers autre chose permet
finalement de de se rendre compte qu'on
est pas seul de se rendre compte que
l'idée qu'on a n'est pas unique de se
rendre compte finalement on n'a pas
toujours raison y compris pour nous il y
a une plateforme officielle spécialisée
dans l'écoute des jeunes j'ai trouvé sur
le site du gouvernement fil santé jeunes
qui répond aux questions tous les jours
de 9h à 23 heures c'est le 0800 235 236
un numéro d'appel anonyme et gratuit je
le dis aussi pour les gens qui nous
écoutent ça peut être utile 0 800 235
236 est-ce qu'il faut une écoute
particulière pour les jeunes car une
nuit blanche
je sais pas si elle doit être
particulière moi j'ai beaucoup travaillé
avec
j'ai beaucoup travaillé avec les
adolescents et j'adore cette période de
la vie parce que je trouve que tout est
encore possible oui tout est encore
possible et puis ils ont une espèce
d'acuité mais je
pense que il faut avec eux avec des avec
des adolescents on peut pas mentir en
fait je trouve ça serait dommage dans
notre métier mais en tout cas ne peut
pas dissimuler il capte très vite les
choses et d'ailleurs leurs parents enfin
ils sont très vite les failles chez
l'adulte donc oui ils sont très vifs
très il y a quelque chose de très
intuitif donc
oui on s'adapte mais je crois qu'en fait
c'est pas tellement différent il faut
leur parler vrai en fait il y a pas
besoin de voyez ça serait ridicule
d'utiliser de se mettre d'utiliser un
vocabulaire jeune enfin ça serait
absolument d'essayer de rentrer dans
leur code il faut pouvoir parce qu'il
vienne chercher ils viennent pas
chercher ça mais je crois que la
difficulté c'est que on a du mal vous
dites les sociétés est-ce que les gens
vont mal je crois que c'est difficile
pour la société pour des politiques de
dire qu'au fond de considérer la
dépression il y a quelque chose encore
de très tabou là-dessus c'est même dans
les entreprises vous dites pas si
quelqu'un est en arrêt maladie alors il
y a le secret médical mais dépression
c'est waouh oui il va pas être fier il
va pas bien et sans aller jusqu'à la
dépression dire que ça va pas très bien
ça va pas très bien
c'est compliqué les gens fuis ça comme
ça tu peux changer quand même la crise
mine de rien nous on le voit justement
ben les appels qui augmentent et les
consultations qui augmentent c'est quand
même un peu plus
admissible enfin il y en a plein qui
probablement ne peuvent pas encore mais
quand même dire qu'on va pas bien dire
qu'on consulte je trouve que depuis là
les trois ans et malheureusement
derrière il faut que nous on puisse
assurer ce qui est pas toujours le cas
mais c'est une démarche qui est quand
même un peu plus je trouve
dans le monde du travail il vaut mieux
pas savoir
sur ces jeunes ils viennent facilement à
vous est-ce qu'il faut les écouter
différemment leur parler différemment
est-ce qu'il y en a de plus en plus
alors les jeunes nous comme le disait de
très bien montré le documentaire nous on
a été
on a écouté dès les premiers jours du
covid on a écouté beaucoup plus de
jeunes
les moins de 24 ans c'est plus 40% en 3
ans donc c'est alors sur plusieurs
milliers de centaines de milliers
d'appels 6% ça paraît pas énorme ça fait
quand même beaucoup beaucoup d'appels ce
qui nous surprend surtout c'est les
moins de 14 ans de 14 15 ans cela on les
avait quasiment jamais et là on les a
alors on les a au téléphone c'est à dire
qu'ils ont redécouvert le téléphone et
je rebondis sur ce que vous disiez
la voix c'est quelque chose de ils sont
sur leurs réseaux sociaux mais ils ont
besoin
et donc nous on a on fait le téléphone
on fait aussi le chat sur le chat les
moins de 24 ans c'est un quart de nos
contacts et les
il a vraiment je fais écho à ce que vous
disiez on est très surpris par les
premiers mots qu'il nous disent sur le
chat c'est est-ce que vous êtes un robot
et est-ce que vous êtes un adulte
c'est-à-dire qui viennent chercher la
parole de l'adulte et effectivement nous
on s'adapte pas du tout au langage jeune
c'est tout ça c'est bon on n'est pas là
pour ça mais il recherche la parole
d'adulte sont souvent des gamins des
jeunes qui sont en rupture dans leur
écosystème au niveau de la famille au
niveau de l'école pas forcément avec des
choses très importantes
ils sont en danger mais en tout cas
qu'il est rend suffisamment mal à l'aise
avec un mal-être qui dont il n'arrive
pas à se défaire et il nous appelle pour
ça et là c'est pas pour nous ça a été
pendant le covid et donc on est très
attentif aujourd'hui encore
pour l'instant ça n'a pas baissé on les
a toujours professeur peniscolo pour
aller rechercher le numéro de téléphone
ou la façon de contacter une plateforme
d'écoute de mal-être il faut quand même
aller très mal non quand on est jeune en
particulier c'est évident et
ça répond à je pense beaucoup beaucoup
d'interrogations en fait ce qui
recherche probablement c'est une écoute
mais surtout quelques réponses sur
pour faire simple quel sens donner à
tout cela parce que ce qui a derrière
c'est quand même cette absence de de
vision ce qui a changé quand même depuis
quelques années c'est qu'on ne s'est
plus très bien où on va quoi dans
complètement les fameux grands repères
sociaux politiques une manière etc ils
sont quand même bien mis à mal et en
particulier les jeunes il y a la
question de du climat et de l'évolution
quand même de l'environnement qui est
très très forte dans leur anxiété cette
fameuse est anxiété d'avoir des
interlocuteurs qui peuvent quand même
leur donner peut-être leur expérience
enfin ce que vous vous faites-vous je
trouve que le terme amitié est-ce que
l'amitié c'est quand même c'est assez
génial donc que comme titre parce que
c'est vrai que nous on est habitué à
chercher des solutions et peut-être que
c'est plus facile pour un professionnel
de se dire bon ben je vais essayer de
faire quelque chose vous vous êtes
obligé de dire je vais être là pendant
un temps et on arrête mais donner de
l'amitié comme ça à quelqu'un c'est
quand même fabuleux je pense que pour
des jeunes peut-être qu'il découvre
quelque chose qui n'existe plus vraiment
dans la vraie vie et puis et puis ce
film pose quand même la question de
l'état de la psychiatrie en France la
réalisatrice a aussi tourné avec les
professionnels de la plateforme du
centre hospitalier le vinassier dans la
région lyonnaise et certains d'entre eux
se disent un peu et c'est un euphémisme
démuni le problème il est surtout que on
n'a pas assez de psychiatre qui a plus
de place depuis qu'on a ouvert live on
arrivait plus facilement à adresser les
gens avant maintenant au niveau
recherche ça devient compliqué des fois
parce que il y a trop d'attentes et les
gens quand ils ont besoin c'est enfin
les patients les agissent c'est
maintenant tout de suite quoi ils vont
mal maintenant ils ont pas besoin d'un
rendez-vous dans 6
six mois ce sera peut-être trop tard
quoi
sur les outils de communication
peut-être qu'on ne peut pas faire
machine arrière mais sur la question de
la psychiatrie est-ce qu'on ne peut pas
faire beaucoup plus et ce qu'il faut
faire beaucoup plus
vous êtes quand même avion en plus donc
c'est vraiment pas un problème au
contraire je considère que depuis
pratiquement la mise en place d'un
tarification à l'activité en MCO la
psychiatrie a été la grande oubliée de
toutes les politiques de santé donc
c'est depuis 2002 le T2A c'est 2002 on
est en 2023 et donc ça fait maintenant
plus de 20 ans que systématiquement dans
chaque projet de loi de financement de
sécurité sociale qui ont été mis en
place la psychiatrie a touché un budget
global sans que l'on considère à aucun
moment qui avait une augmentation de de
moyens à donner parce qu'il y a une des
besoins pourquoi ça n'a jamais été
pourquoi la psychiatrie est-elle le
parent pauvre de la médecine française
je sais pas moi il faut poser la
question parce que personne moi je me
serais battu pour qu'elle ait qu'elle en
ait plus mais pourquoi peut-être parce
que au bout du compte
la santé en général a été considéré plus
en MCO comme psychiatrie de la part de
ceux qui décident et ce
médecine chirurgie obstétrique les
hôpitaux classiques hors psychiatrie et
parce que les les hôpitaux
psychiatriques à côté la psychiatrie a
toujours été considérée comme une
spécialité de la médecine bien sûr mais
que finalement à la marge parce que les
malades psychiatriques finalement à
partir du moment où les psychiatres s'en
occupaient était pas nécessaire je pense
là je suis en train d'accuser mais il
n'était pas nécessaire de de faire en
sorte qu'on puisse les sortir de leur
maladie alors maintenant grâce
d'ailleurs aux recherches qui sont dans
le service du professeur et avec ses
collègues on s'aperçoit que même en
matière de psychiatrie les mêmes les
maladies psychiatriques les plus dures
je pense en particulier
à la maladie bipolaire on trouve des
traitements efficaces chimiques efficace
donc il est nécessaire que l'on revoit
mais ça fait des années qu'on le dit
avec Monsieur mais la psychiatrie c'est
large financement de tout cela je lisais
qu'une personne sur quatre était
confrontée au cours de sa vie un trouble
mental on est déjà dans la psychiatrie
quand on a un début de dépression c'est
pas forcément la schizophrénie ou la
bipolarité il faut 20 ans une vingtaine
d'années parfois une dizaine d'années
disons entre 10 et 20 ans pour
diagnostiquer une maladie psychiatrique
quand on dit il faut plus de moyens plus
d'effectifs dans la psychiatrie c'est de
quel ordre quelle proportion c'est
combien professeur Pélisson alors grand
débat mais en tout cas les raisons
puisque c'était ça que vous demandiez
elles sont sûrement très nombreuses
elles sont sociologiques à le regard sur
la folie la peur etc l'exclusion et puis
je peux vous dire même
cherchant des médecins on passe toujours
un peu après enfin c'est pas pour
plaiser pour ma chapelle mais c'est
toujours effectivement ce qu'on fait à
la fin la psychiatrie alors on est en
train de communiquer pour que ça change
c'est sûr et quand on voit les effectifs
enfin les le nombre de personnes
concernées une personne sur quatre une
personne sur 5 à peu près en effet c'est
très varié ça peut être des choses de la
dépression qui vont se résoudre assez
facilement entre guillemets que à partir
du moment où on est aidé et puis des
choses plus lourdes mais en tout cas ça
concerne en gros tout le monde parce
qu'une personne sur quatre ça veut dire
qu'on a tous des proches qui sont
concernés donc maintenant on peut pas
mettre ça sous le tapis alors donc
ensuite il y a reconstruire un système
parce que en effet ça fait 20 ans 30 ans
que on a laissé les choses un peu
dépérir et donc c'est évidemment très
long parce que ça veut dire qu'il faut
former des gens par exemple former des
gens ça prend des années donc même si on
investit et il faut investir plus que
même ce qui est fait aujourd'hui il y a
eu un effort ces dernières années mais
c'est pas encore suffisant pour l'enfant
et l'adolescent par exemple que vous
évoquiez qui est vraiment le vraiment le
noyau de la crise je pense qu'il
effectivement il faudrait doubler les
budgets pour faire simple et caricatural
c'est doublé pour la psychiatrie
d'adulte c'est peut-être pas à ce niveau
là mais ça veut dire plus de notre seul
outil de soins c'est la relation humaine
c'est à dire des personnes on peut pas
payer des machines enfin il y en a il y
en a pas on va pas se remplacer par des
robots à nouveau donc il faut payer des
gens et des gens c'est du temps c'est de
la formation et on sait que ça coûte
mais voilà et et ça entre guillemets ça
rapporte parce qu'on sait bien que ces
personnes là qui ne vont plus au travail
qui consomment d'autres soins des
médicaments ça a un coût pour la nation
c'est gigantesque le coup des maladies
mentales pour la nation donc on
investissant en plus on aurait même des
économies alors c'est plus tard c'est
sûr que c'est difficile pour les
politiques de se dire bon ben j'investis
maintenant mais incontournable
non vous avez raison parce que il y a un
coût alors les politiques devraient se
pencher là-dessus parce que s'ils
veulent pas voir le coup humain sur un
plan économique quelqu'un qui ne peut
pas avoir de rendez-vous je pense aussi
au centre médico-psychologique qui était
la psychiatrie de secteur justement pour
que ça soit accessible à tout un chacun
où les consultations pouvaient être
gratuites moi j'ai beaucoup de de
personnes qui me disent que les délais
d'attentes ça peut être six mois qui a
de moins en moins de psychiatre qui
tournent sur plusieurs centres
médico-psychologiques donc il voit des
infirmiers psychiatriques qui sont très
bien enfin il y a un vrai problème de
recrutement aussi des des psychiatres
c'est de moins en moins de psychiatre je
m'abuse dans mes jeunes
et cette psychiatrie de secteur qui
était faite pour pour soigner
malheureusement des des centres fermes
et quelqu'un qui va mal et le disait
très bien dans le documentaire il peut
se dégrader rapidement s'il se dégradent
rapidement il va peut-être falloir une
hospitalisation c'est un coup il pourra
plus travailler donc enfin si on
agissait maintenant si on prenait les
problèmes au début on éviterait des
hospitalisations longues je dis
hospitalisées si on l'ongle on voit même
que des personnes atteintes de psychose
malheureusement la durée
d'hospitalisation se réduit aussi alors
qu'on sait que le temps psychique et pas
le temps de la vie Ghislaine de Sahel
oui moi nous au niveau de SOS Amitié de
tous les services d'écoute c'est
vraiment quelque chose qu'on sent très
bien montrer dans le documentaire cette
dégradation de
voilà de la santé au niveau psy nous on
la reçoit complètement entre les
passions qu'on l'habitude d'avoir des
rendez-vous qui sont suivis etc ce qui
voudrait entrer dans ce parcours là et
qui ne peuvent pas alors nous on ne
donne pas de conseils particulièrement
mais voilà on essaye toujours un peu de
savoir si quand on sent que c'est un
petit peu un petit peu lourd s'ils sont
suivis ou pas on n'est pas directif on
va pas leur demander mais il se livre
là-dessus et on voit bien la dégradation
et donc effectivement il nous appelle
alors ça me fait toujours rire quand je
dis ça mais
le week-end par exemple on a beaucoup
plus de gens le week-end qui sont suivis
psy et des fois ils nous disent
spontanément mais c'est mon psy qui m'a
donné votre numéro parce que il est pas
là il travaille pas le week-end alors
c'est bien parce qu'il faut du repos
mais bon nous ça nous fait un petit peu
sourire mais sourire jaune pourquoi
parce qu'effectivement on sait très bien
que les personnes
elles font pas un stop pendant le
week-end quoi donc voilà s'il y a une
urgence il faut il faut être là
sur sur la question que vous m'avez
posée parce que pourquoi est-ce que on
n'a pas fait plus d'efforts financiers
par rapport à MCO
même dans la dans les conversations ou
dans les discours on entend parfois des
gens dire on va pas être autiste
stigmatisant ou quand on vous parle et
qu'on vous dit bah finalement on va
essayer de pas faire de la schizophrénie
c'est stigmatisant et cette
stigmatisation se répercute
obligatoirement ensuite dans la mise en
place des financements c'est une
obligation peut-être pour conclure
Ghislaine de scène le numéro de
téléphone qu'il faut composer pour
joindre SOS Amitié et est-ce qu'il y en
a beaucoup d'autres est-ce que c'est
très lisible est-ce qu'il y en a un
commun comment on fait alors il y a une
plateforme commune et puis on a conservé
les numéros locaux parce qu'avant chaque
association locale avait son propre
numéro c'était plutôt régional on a
conservé ces numéros là parce qu'on a
quelques habitués qui avait l'habitude
d'appeler ils préfèrent appeler un 03 21
par exemple pour pour les hauts de
France plutôt 15 09 mais ceci étant la
plateforme elle est commune donc c'est
ce qui nous a permis de la mise en place
de cette plateforme nous a permis de
prendre 25% d'appel en plus au niveau
national
un dernier mot il y a une nouveauté
quand même ces dernières années c'est
pour les personnes qui ont des moments
très difficiles notamment des crises
suicidaires et un numéro de prévention
du suicide qui est quand même un gros
progrès parce que c'est des
professionnels c'est 31 14 314 donc si
on doit retenir en tout cas un numéro
important pour ceux qui auraient dépensé
suicidaires c'est le 31 14 c'est bien
noté merci merci beaucoup à tous les
quatre d'avoir participé à cet échange
merci à vous de nous avoir suivis comme
chaque semaine à très vite sur Public
Sénat
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]